merci beaucoup voilà
c'est fait mon festif pour un nouveau
départ le Medef des Yvelines inauguré
son nouveau siège ce mercredi 6
septembre à Montigny-le-Bretonneux open
space lumineux bureau et salon pour
recevoir les adhérents près d'une
centaine d'entrepreneurs et de
personnalités politiques du département
avait fait le déplacement pour découvrir
ses locaux de 155 mètres carrés
c'est notre huitième projet de
déménagement c'est pas simple de
déménager une entreprise l'échelle
d'entreprise le savent c'est pas simple
pour nous aussi
c'est beaucoup de projets des beaux
négocier des agences immobilières à
rencontrer auparavant installer sur
Versailles le Medef des Yvelines a
délocalisé ici son siège en janvier 2023
un changement encouragé par un besoin de
locaux plus spacieux nécessaire pour
recevoir les adhérents dans de bonnes
conditions un choix aussi marqué par la
volonté de s'implanter sur un territoire
d'entreprise finalement on a privilégié
50 ans qui est un centre d'affaires qui
est un cœur économique donc c'est une
ville est beaucoup de salariés avec les
fonctions qui vont avec je pense aux
transports en commun qui sont quand même
assez exceptionnels à la proximité avec
Paris parce que les lignes c'est 23
minutes
et puis on a de très bonnes relations
avec l'intercommunalité de 50 ans en
Yvelines mais l'idée ici c'est quand
même de pouvoir développer quelque chose
de très comme en dynamique pour que les
chefs d'entreprises se connaissent au
niveau du territoire des Yvelines depuis
le sud jusqu'au nord implanté dans tous
l'Hexagone le Mouvement des Entreprises
de France est composé d'environ 70% de
TPE PME dans les Yvelines se portent
parole des entrepreneurs comptent
environ 250 adhérents